[Musique]
c'est au village corail que s'est
organisée la journée de lancement du
premier réseau régal dédié à la lutte
contre le gaspillage alimentaire dans
les dom
chaque année des tonnes de nourriture
consomamtion gaspiller l'action de régal
réunion est de valoriser et de
développer les compétences des
différents acteurs c'est ce que nous
rappelle madame duchemann conseillère
départementale est donc ce matin c'était
pour présenter ce dispositif qui est un
dispositif qui va mettre en lien en
réseau tous les acteurs qui tournent
autour de l'alimentation et qui peuvent
donc pas de par leurs actions générées
du gaspillage alimentaire est donc là
vous avez là bien entendu tout ce qui
est entreprise commerciale voire même
production de déchets bois et artisans
commerçants et vous avez aussi de
l'autre côté l'institution les
collectivités et notamment celles qui
ont des restaurations scolaires
donc ça commence depuis l'école primaire
jusqu'à l'université
depuis l'année dernière le département a
lancé le concours nos gaspille un
concours dont l'objectif est de lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaires dans
les cantines scolaires des collèges
c'est ce que nous rappelle madame
soubadou vice présidents des collèges et
de l'éducation
c'est un peu ce que nous avons déjà
contre le gaspillage alimentaire de nos
collèges à travers d'eco kokou métro
donc aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion en
fait de montrer aussi ce que le
département a su faire pour notre
jeunesse réunionnaise et ce partenariat
va faire que nous allons travailler en
complémentarité avec ce réseau pour
justement apporter notre savoir faire et
dire combien depuis deux ans
c'est la troisième année que le concours
est mise en place et depuis deux ans là
la motivation et l'ambition de notre
jeunesse dans les collèges qui ont su
prouver que ils savent ne pas gaspiller
et le résultat il est là il ya moins de
30% en tous les cas de gaspillage ce qui
est important aujourd'hui
face à ces enjeux le conseil
départemental se positionne comme le
chef de file et s'engage aux côtés de
l'ensemble des acteurs de la chaîne
alimentaire
[Musique]